well joining us now is the former
director of Professional Standards for
the Metropolitan Police that's Stephen
Roberts hello to Mr Roberts thank you
for joining us um intrigued to know your
comments on this story today
I think what we have to remember is that
at the heart of this there is a
desperately anxious family and we need
to be very very careful that nothing
that we do nothing that we say and
nothing that politicians or the media
say uh makes their situation worse the
media can help the senior investigating
officer needs public awareness needs to
find perhaps that one person who has a
little item of evidence that he may or
may not even know that he has perhaps a
dash cam a piece of film so there needs
to be public awareness it needs to be
kept in front of the public
but the sio has a very difficult job
balancing that need to attract media
attention with the needs of the privacy
of the family and the needs uh to not
hinder the investigation with rumor uh
by disclosing anything that might help
the investigation so it's a very
difficult balance to strike and police
officers have become very used to the
idea that they what they do must be
transparent well that isn't always
possible in a major investigation like
this sometimes it's absolutely essential
to keep some details back from the
public the public may be interested and
the police require the public to be
interested but there is not a public
interest in everything being disclosed
do you think it was reasonable though I
mean there's been a lot of Christmas
criticism not least from the Home
Secretary it would appear in the shadow
Home Secretary about the sort of very
personal detail about uh this missing
lady Nicola bully and the impact that
that has had on her family
absolutely as soon as I heard uh the
first question being answered that the
uh statement that uh Ms bully had
specific vulnerabilities it was
blindingly obvious I have to say that
the next question was going to be well
what are those vulnerabilities
what we don't know and what we should
not judge at this stage is why that
disclosure was made it may simply have
been ill-judged and whilst I hate
criticizing my former colleagues it may
simply have been a misjudgment and a bad
misjudgment at that but there may be
some basic reason within the
investigation within the other
information that the police already have
that made it helpful to make that
disclosure we simply cannot judge at
this stage and I I just heard your crime
correspondent saying what the police and
what the senior investigating officer
need now is a period of calm where
they're allowed to get on with their job
without interference from politicians
and without amateur detectives second
guessing the investigation
oh yeah um that was Martin brunt who was
making those comments um I'm I'm sure
that many people would also agree with
you as well but of course there might be
a moment where you know the police have
to accept that they may never find her
oh absolutely that's the case and we can
think back over decades to missing
persons cases where the person who
disappeared was never found
uh sometimes that is so sometimes there
simply isn't any evidence any physical
evidence uh any human evidence of what
has happened to an individual sometimes
tragically we and families are left with
that mystery that he's never sold
okay thank you so much for taking the
time to join us very much appreciated